hyrule warriors agent calamity is
finally out and features much tougher
battles than what you might have played
in the demo
i've also found some interesting tech
that will be extra useful for those of
you who want to get really deep into the
intricacies of combat
so this will be the premiere of a few
neat agent calamity tricks so here are
six combat tips that will help you tear
through the battlefield
if you're throwing out stasis
willy-nilly and using the stasis auto
animation you've got to change your ways
while using the stasis to counter a
stasis weak attack is a good natural
application of the ability the most
powerful part of stasis is the potential
to extend weak point time and create
more stun
you capitalize on this by dashing after
you perform the stasis to freely do any
action after freezing them
while some weak points last quite a
while for you to wail in your opponent
some just last a second or so which
isn't enough time to crack it so use
stasis to extend that time
this application is crucial to extending
combos gaining more meter and reducing
the enemies freedom to fight back
unfortunately not every character has
the ability to attack on their own
during stasis daruk for example is
unable to follow up but for characters
who can
this is incredibly powerful this can
even be tied to user created weak points
forcing your way through an opponent's
weak point at any time you'll want to be
cracking this weak point as much as
possible as weak point smashes are the
highest damaging attacks in the game
and enemies on very hard mode are very
tanky so do not underestimate this
technique
for all of you who know me i like to
find secret combat tricks that might be
pretty nifty in a fight here's a couple
that i found with a couple characters
i coined the herbosa float cancel which
is executed while airborne and attacking
by tapping your zr charge midair your
attack count will be reset
allowing you to continue attacking in
the air this flying orbozo trick will
continue to headshot most enemies while
being out of their attacking range
and still doing damage it is possible to
get hit with certain high attacks but
this technique dodges most ground
attacks while dishing out damage from
above
i also found a unique technique with
rivali which i named rune sliding by
doing your flight c4 combo and timing a
sheikah slate ability perfectly
you can slide along the ground at
breakneck speeds depending on your rune
of choice
some slides last longer than others but
whichever one you choose the utility
changes with your speedy movement and
during the entire length of the
animation you are completely invincible
this can be handy for approaching pesky
ranged enemies or
possibly even speed running
[Music]
age of calamity doesn't really explain
how rods work all that well so i'll
break it down in depth because it is
important
elemental rods create weak points at any
time if you're having trouble creating
an opening but the type of weak point
and the size of the blast depends on
several things
first to get it out of the way it's
important to note that rods that attack
enemies of the same element have
zero effect so obviously don't hit an
ice enemy with an ice rod
second hitting enemies with an element
that is weak against fire against ice
ice against fire automatically do a
critical weak point which is extremely
powerful weak point attack that creates
a longer lasting and more fragile weak
point gauge
third and most important is the power
and size of the blast depends on the
terrain you hit
you can see this when hovering your fire
rod over grassed dirt
fire on grassy areas lightning on metal
or water and ice on water
increases the blast range and forces a
critical weak point even those to not
normally leak to them
so always pay attention to your
surroundings and take advantage of the
terrain you're on
most characters in the game are able to
fail a magnesius if nothing metallic is
around
well you might think that's stupid
what's the point but actually this is
arguably one of the more powerful
techniques in the game
because it almost cancels any action you
do and also gives you complete
invincibility at any time without using
any resources you can perform this by
simply pressing r and b
with no metallic items in range in
situations where a regular dodge is
difficult to do
you can use a magnesius cancel to dodge
damaging attacks or cancel out of long
animations you want to get out of you'll
want to keep in mind that this varies
from character to character as some like
zelda are unable to do this technique at
all
while others like impa are able to spam
this quickly over and over
and also if there are metallic items
around you'll do your regular magnesis
attack which for most characters is
pretty underwhelming
but when the situation is right
magnesius cancel can be very clutch
some attacks such as guardian lasers
have a blast hitbox that are hard to
dodge
and can't be parried with other
characters so keep this in your
repertoire to pull out against deadly
foes
i don't usually like to promote easy
wins but it's hard to ignore a character
like impa who is 100 triple as tier on
this tier list she can nearly infinite
enemies solo control crowds and stun
everybody around her while doing so
it's possible in the future that other
characters may have some hidden
potential that will place just as high
on a tier list but the demo is pretty
telling of impulse powers and in the end
game with more powers unlocked
i have to say she's even more of an
absolute monster if for some reason
you're having a hard time with this game
you can lean on this chica pain train to
carry you through a rough mission
i can go into a detailed explanation of
why she is broken but it's not really
necessary you can just see from the
footage here
[Music]
this technique can help out in a pinch
if you're really having a tough time
pairing and dodging
by alternating the slate and wand menus
you could put yourself in a perpetual
state of slowdown which can give you
much more accurate windows to dodge and
parry attacks
some attacks have strange hitboxes or
animations that speed up or slow down
so if you need a second to study and
watch went to a counter attack you can
use this little trick to assist you with
timing
so there are your six tips to help you
with many battles you will have in
hyrule and if you have any more tips
post them down below
we're always looking for cool stuff to
find in age of calamity thanks for
watching
[Music]